♪ ♪
>> Greg: GOVERNOR CUOMO BARRED
PEOPLE FROM VISITING THEIR LOVED
ONES IN NURSING HOMES.
THE STATE SIMULTANEOUSLY
ENFORCED IN THE SAME PLACES.
AN EXTRA 7000 DEATHS AND THE
DEATH COUNT 5,000.
SO UNLIKE OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD WHERE PEOPLE TRY TO SLOW
THE SPREAD, THIS ACTION
ACCELERATED IT.
THANK GOD CHRIS CUOMO PRESSED
HIS BROTHER ON IT.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT YOU ARE AN
ATTRACTIVE PERSON NOW BECAUSE
YOU ARE SINGLE AND READY TO
MINGLE?
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU ARE SOME
DESIRABLE SINGLE PERSON, AND
THIS IS NOT JUST PEOPLE PAYING
YOU COMING OUT AT THEM?
>> I THINK BEAUTY IS IN THE EYE
OF THE BEHOLDER.
>> Greg: WELL, IT HELPS TO
HAVE A BROTHER IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS AND A BROTHER IN
GOVERNMENT.
SCANDALS DISAPPEAR WITH A BIG
SHRUG.
PLUS IT MORE TIME TO BASH
PETRONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT AT REOPENING
OUR COUNTRY WILL LIKELY KILL
MORE OF US, BUT WE HAVE TO GET
OUR COUNTRY BACK.
HOW CAN HE ACCEPT THAT WHEN HE
HASN’T EVEN COME CLOSE TO DOING
WHAT HE CAN TO AVOID MORE PAIN
AND DEATH?
>> Greg: , OH, REALLY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK THEY SHUT DOWN IS?
EVIL SELFISH TRUMP WOULD CRATER
OF THE ECONOMY EVER FOR AND
GIGGLES?
WAIT, YOU PROBABLY DO.
AND IN CASE YOU MISSED IT WE ARE
SPENDING TRILLIONS, WHY IS THAT?
THE PRESIDENT HAS MENTIONED THAT
MORE THAN YOU.
>> President Trump: THERE HAS
BEEN SO MUCH UNNECESSARY DEATH
IN THE COUNTRY.
AFTER ALL THIS DEATH, DEATH THAT
WE ARE SUFFERING, THE WHOLE
WORLD IS SUFFERING THE POSSIBLE
NUMBER OF DEATH COUNTRIES NOW
ARE SUFFERING.
IT HAS BEEN A HORRIBLE TIME TO
SEE SUCH DEATH.
TREMENDOUS DEATH AND ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION.
THE VIRUS INFLICTED IMMENSE
PHYSICAL SUFFERING MANY PEOPLE,
BUT ALSO MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
SUFFERING.
>> Greg: OF COURSE, CUOMO
IGNORED THAT LIKE THE SEVERE
STEPS TRUMP IS TAKEN TO FIGHT
THE VIRUS, WHICH DIDN’T INCLUDE
ISSUING DEATH SENTENCES FOR THE
ELDERLY IN NURSING HOMES.
YOU JUST KNOW THE MEDIA WISHES
THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE THEY
COULD HAVE PINNED ON TRUMP,
WHICH REMINDS ME OF ANOTHER
IGNORED STORY INVOLVING AN
ANCHOR WHO SCHOOLED YOU FOR
VIOLATING SHUTDOWNS.
>> LOOK AT THESE FOOLS, FOOLS!
I KNOW THEY WANT TO BE OUT
THERE, POOLS!
IT’S NOT ABOUT YOU.
WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER PEOPLE?
LOOK, I’M NOT GOING TO CASTIGATE
YOU.
I’M NOT THERE THAT’S NOT MY JOB.
I’M NOT YOUR DADDY.
>> Greg: YOU MUST REMEMBER
THAT INCIDENT WITH THE
BICYCLIST, RIGHT?
HOW DID CUOMO FIGHT WITH THIS
GUY WHILE HE WAS IN QUARANTINE?
>> I DON’T WANT SOME JACK
[BLEEP] LOSER FAT TIRE BIKER TO
BE ABLE TO PULL OVER AND GET IN
MY FACE AND IN MY SPACE AND TALK
[BLEEP] TO ME.
I DON’T WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> Greg: THAT HAPPENED BEFORE
HE STAGED THAT MIRACULOUS
EMERGENCE FROM HIS BASEMENT.
SO CHRIS FACES MORE OUTRAGE NOT
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY, BUT
FROM YOU, EVEN THOUGH HE IS NO
ANGEL.
BUT HEY, CNN, NOTHING IS BETTER
THAN BROTHERLY LOVE, INCLUDING
THE TRUTH.
SO KATIE, WHO CAME UP WITH THIS
IDEA TO SHUTTLE INFECTED
PATIENTS INTO THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION?
IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
YOU HAVE THIS GIANT SHIP ON WEST
SIDE HIGHWAY, RIGHT, THAT WAS
UNDER UNDERUSED.
AND YOU HAVE THE JAVITS CENTER
AND USE -- IN A WAY, THAT IS MY
QUESTION.
>> Katie: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO ASK ME WHO CAME UP WITH
THE CUOMO BROTHER INTERVIEW.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE PEOPLE AT THE
NURSING HOME AND THE GOVERNMENT
HAVE DECIDED IT WAS A GOOD IDEA
TO PUT ELDERLY PEOPLE WHO WERE
INFECTED BACK INTO THE NURSING
HOMES DESPITE EVIDENCE PRIOR TO
THIS THAT SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE
OF THE DISEASE SPREADS IN THESE
NURSING HOMES.
AS YOU REMEMBER THE FIRST CASES
WERE IN WASHINGTON STATE IN THE
NURSING HOME WHERE WE HAD THE
FIRST DEATH OF THE DISEASE.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GAVE USNS
COMFORT SCUM OF THE
JAVITS CENTER THAT WENT WIDELY
UNUSED AND YET, INSTEAD THEY
TOOK PEOPLE WHO WERE SICK AND
PUT THEM BACK INTO A VULNERABLE
POPULATION INSIDE AND THEN THERE
WERE CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE
PEOPLE DYING.
IT IS JUST HORRIBLE.
SOMEBODY SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR IT.
>> Greg: JUAN EVEN THOUGH THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BLAME TRUMP OR
ANYTHING, I WILL NOT BLAME
ANDREW CUOMO FOR THIS.
SHOULD WE BLAME IT ON TRUMP
ANYWAY JUST TO GET IT OUT OF THE
WAY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I THINK THAT WOULD
MAKE YOU HAPPY.
I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE YOUR
DAY, MAN, THAT IS LIKE CLINT
EASTWOOD.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE REALITIES
IS, YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT CUOMO.
LET ME TELL YOU, I DON’T THINK
CUOMO IS ALL THAT POPULAR AT
LEAST PRIOR TO THIS IN NEW YORK
STATE, BUT NOW HIS POPULARITY IS
WAY UP THERE NATIONALLY.
WHICH IS AMAZING TO ME
POLITICALLY.
BUT I THINK IT IS AS A RESULT OF
THOSE AFTERNOON BRIEFINGS.
AND I THINK HE IS STILL THE
VOICE BECAUSE HE’S GOING HARD
WITH THE POWER POINTS AND THE
FACTS AND ALL OF THAT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST
SAID, YOU KNOW I’M AT THIS IT’S
INTERESTING AND STARTED TO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT HE WAS
SCIENCE-BASED.
SO I GUESS THAT OPENED THE DOOR.
WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN HE GETS THIS
TV TIME WAY BEYOND HIS BROTHER,
BUT YES, INCLUDING FROM HIS
BROTHER AND THOSE SILLY
QUESTIONS ABOUT BEING SINGLE AND
READY TO MINGLE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, DANA, TO
JUAN’S POINT IS POPULAR AMONG
THE MEDIA.
THE MEDIA KEEPS TALKING HE
SCIENCE-BASED, FACT-BASED AND
ISN’T HE AWESOME BUT THEY CHOOSE
TO NOT LOOK AT THE NURSING HOME
SCANDAL OR THAT HE WAS EGGING ON
POPULATION TO ACTUALLY LIVE A
NORMAL LIFE AT THE OUTBREAK AS
IT STARTED.
>> Dana: SO I WAS WATCHING, IN
FACT, WATCHING HIS BRIEFING
YESTERDAY.
HE WAS GOING ON.
I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE THINK IT
IS ENTERTAINING WITH ALL THESE
POWER POINTS AND HE’S UP THERE
WITH A PROFESSOR ANY TUNE INTO
CLASS EVERY DAY.
BUT HE GOES TO TAKE QUESTIONS
AND THE FIRST QUESTION IS ABOUT
THESE NURSING HOMES AND THESE
DEATHS.
HE SAID, I DON’T REALLY KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT -- YEAH, NO.
DO YOU WANT TO ANSWER THAT?
AND HE TURNS IT OVER TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
THESE QUESTIONS WILL KEEP COMING
UP, AND ESPECIALLY,
BILL de BLASIO THE MAYOR HAS
ALREADY BEEN ASKED ABOUT THIS.
AND HE IMMEDIATELY SAID, OH, IT
HAS TO BE PRIVATE EQUITIES,
PRIVATE EQUITY COMPANIES THAT
INVESTED INTO NURSING HOMES.
BUT SOMEONE HAD TO MAKE THE
GUIDANCE AND THE RULING TO SEND
BACK TO THE NURSING HOME AND NOT
THE PLACES SUGGESTED APPEARED
I’M NOT THE BEST AT WHAT ABOUT
ISMS, THE CAMERA CAUGHT ME
TOUCHING MY FACE SO I WILL GET
SOME KIND OF VIOLATION
BECAUSE YOU’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
TOUCH YOUR FACE AND JESSE TOLD
US THAT, BUT I HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT IF JESSE WATTERS HAD BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH CORONAVIRUS AND
HE HAD BEEN IN HIS BASEMENT AND
HE HAD BEEN DOING ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND THEN HE WAS THE ONE
WHO GOT IN A FIGHT WITH THE
LOSER SATIRE.
DO YOU THINK THAT JESSE WATTERS
WOULD HAVE EVER HEARD THE END OF
THAT?
INSTEAD OF, NOPE, CNN ACTUALLY
PUT A MOCKERY EMERGENCE AND A
FAKE REEMERGENCE FOR THE
CAMERAS.
LIKE IMAGINE IF WE DID THAT.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT IS
FUNNY, YOU MADE A VERY ASTUTE
COMPARISON BETWEEN CHESSIE AND
CHRIS COLUMBO.
I NEVER THOUGHT OF THIS BEFORE.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU ARE OUR CHRIS CUOMO.
JESSE, I’M KIDDING.
I’M KIDDING.
SPEED TO GO AFTER JESSE MAN,
COME ON, DON’T DO THAT.
>> Jesse: THAT IS THE ONE
ABOUT-ISM THAT I APPROVE OF.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THIS, THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE WITH THE
HIGHEST DEATH COUNT WHO TOLD
EVERYBODY NOT TO WORRY ABOUT
THIS THING AND WHO SHUTTLED
PEOPLE IN THE NURSING HOME,
BEING INTERVIEWED BY HIS BROTHER
WHO GOT INFECTED BY WHO KNOWS
HOW, MAYBE NOT WASHING HIS
HANDS, BROKE QUARANTINE AND NOW
SCHILLING FOR CHINA.
AND THE MEDIA THINKS THAT IS
GREAT.
BECAUSE THAT IS ALL THAT CNN
HAS.
THIS IS LIKE DON JR.
INTERVIEWING ERIC AND THE REST,
OH, THAT WAS GREAT.
THAT WAS A GREAT INTERVIEW,